[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le 78 loisir toutes vos idées
sorties dans les départements et on
commence tout de suite avec le sommaire
de ce numéro guitare saturée et décibel
au programme de la salle de la tour à
voisin le Bretonneux le festival
mettalsphère revient pour une nouvelle
édition les 12 et 13 mai le président de
metasos organisateur de l'événement nous
rejoindra en place pour nous en parler
et dans le cadre de ces expositions la
commanderie des Templiers organise des
ateliers robotiques assembler et souder
les composants soi-même rien de mieux
pour apprendre comment fonctionne une
machine et un événement pour les plus
petits et leurs parents attrape pour
notre rendez-vous junior Mélanie poqu
nous parlera de la fête de la petite
enfance et si nous prenions un peu de
hauteur pour admirer la beauté que nous
offre la nature François Boiseau expose
ses clichés à Villepreux à la mairie et
à la médiathèque le Nautilus avec ces
photographies le visiteur s'envole pour
contempler les paysages vus du ciel des
photos prises essentiellement en France
et qui pourrai parfois se confondre avec
des aquarelles François Boiseau nous a
parlé de son travail
écoutez ce qui m'inspire c'est euh les
lieux où il y a des des formes euh et
des couleurs très spécifiques donc ça
peut être effectivement les bords de de
de mer euh ça peut être aussi les champs
par exemple en ce moment il y a les
champs de cols avec le jaune et le vert
ça fait des des trucs assez incroyables
je trouve qu'on arrive quand même à une
forme de pureté dans le dans l'image
euh que je retrouve essentiellement dans
la dans la photo aérienne à chaque fois
il se recrée de nouvelles images et
c'est jamais jamais terminé quoi c'est
ça aussi qui est intéressant et dans le
cadre de l'exposition une conférence
aura lieu samedi 6 mai sur le thème
volet en montagne elle sera animée par
deux pilotes et ingénieurs rendez-vous à
16h à la médiatque le Nautilus le 10 mai
débute la 14e édition du Versailles Jazz
Festival 7 jours de jazz de folk mais
aussi de spectacle et notamment pour les
plus jeunes toute la programmation est à
retrouver sur le site internet du
festival et pour se mettre en appétit je
vous propose d'écouter un extrait du
groupe d'ouverture Madeleine et Salomon
le concert est à 20h30 mercredi 10
[Musique]
mai
et on change de style pour une musique
un peu plus extrême les 12 et 13 mai
voisin le bretonne va vibrer au rythme
du métal et du hardcore 6e édition du
festival metétalsphè organisé par
metasos et avec nous son président
tuanmin cujot pour nous parler de la
programmation bonjour tuanminine bonjour
Alors je le disais le festival a lieu
sur de jours on va d'abord parler du
vendredi 12 ma alors quels sont les
groupes qui vont ouvrir le bal alors on
va voir on va vraiment être sur
différents styles au au sein du métal
c'est vraiment le principe d'avoir une
programmation éclectique donc pour
ouvrir le bal on va avoir un groupe
francilien qui s'appelle white SPRE
disease qui font du descore donc un son
très brutal des voix très très saturées
ce qu'on peut appeler des breakdown où
on va avoir vraiment des des grosses
pauses dans le dans le son euh ensuite
on va enchaîner avec desvours de fetus
donc groupe pareil francilien donc qui
font dans un genre assez assez extrême
qui est le brutal des avec des
techniques qui qui s'appelleent le gros
le pix whel qui sont des techniques de
voie par rien on reste dans des styles
tout aussi extrêmes caractéristiqu du
style justement tout à fait euh ensuite
on a un groupe qui répète chez nous à
masos qui s'appelle inner reflections là
on est beaucoup plus sur du hardcore
trash donc un un style un peu plus
inspiré de groupe comme pantherra par
exemple lambe of God euh donc on est
très content parce que c'est un groupe
qui est en qui est qui est émergent qui
a sorti un album un EP différents clips
visibles sur Youtube et qui du coup
répètent chez nous donc ça ça fait très
plaisir et après on va terminer avec the
Prestige groupe parisien qui fait du
hardcore alternatif donc avec des
passages un peu plus post des moments un
peu plus mélodique et la tête d'affiche
donc de ce soir là sera psycup donc
groupe toulousain qui a une vingtaine
d'années déjà d'existance qui fait font
du un métal assez expérimental on peut
dire l'expression un peu barrée donc qui
vont avoir différ beaucoup de de
différents passages des des passages
très rapides d'autres plus lancinant des
voix assez des voix un peu torturées et
pour citer des des grands noms parce que
tout à l'heure vous avez cité un petit
peu Pantera Lemb OFG qu'est-ce qu'on
peut citer un petit peu dans ces
influence de tous ces groupes-là euh ou
là ou là beaucoup beaucoup d'influence
on va retrouver après sur des des gros
groupes euh bah donc des prémisses du
metétal corp avec des groupes comme euh
Bullet For My Valentine
euh converge on peut se retrouver aussi
euh aussi bien oui les vieux groupes de
trashes type layer donc comme je le
disais bien sûr panterra qu'on peut
citer comme un peu les empereurs du
Group
métal voilà après c'est c'est vraiment
très très varié il y a c'est le principe
des groupes souvent c'est de puiser dans
différentes influences pour construire
après leur son pas juste faire le
copiercoller d'un groupe qu'ils aiment
quoi leur propre identité c'est ça tout
à fait et alors on va passer à la
journée de samedi maintenant avec encore
cinq groupes qui vont s'enchaîner on le
rappelle c'est sur la salle c'est dans
la salle de la tour à tout à fait donc
après plusieurs éditions qu'on a fait
que ce soit en Indo ou en extérieur on a
décidé de garder plutôt le format indoor
donc là le samedi on va ouvrir avec un
groupe de gent alors le gent c'est quoi
c'est c'est un un énorme son très saturé
des
parties des parties musicales
instrumentales asymétrique on est pas
juste sur du 1 2 des des mesures en 4
ans on va avoir du 7 ans des changement
de des changements de mesure des
changements de rythme qui sont pas
forcément euh comment dire euh un peu
qui viennent pas naturellement quoi on n
pas sur sur une musique type pop ou
électro euh et donc oui comme je disais
donc une grosse saturation des guitares
des des changements inspirés du des
changements de de de phase inspirés du
du métal progressif on va vooir des
phases plus brutales des phases beaucoup
plus mélodiques donc ce groupe s'appelle
everythinging behind toujours un groupe
francilien ensuite on va avoir un groupe
au style beaucoup plus old school donc
il s'appelle les birdad Bastard qui font
PRU hardcore type teinté teinté de punk
pour barbu puisque le thème de leurs
chansons sont principalement la barbe
pour ça il s'appelle The Bird Bastard un
petit peu d'humour voilà c'est ça tout
c'est vraiment un principe dans le métal
d'avoir toujours ce côté un peu
décalé second degré tout à fait je vis
juste passer tout de suite un petit peu
à la tête d'affiche alors du coup du
samedi alors qu'est-ce que c'est que le
groupe alors la tête d'affiche du samedi
bah ça va être hypnose donc groupe qui
fait du du métal cinématographique donc
qui inclut donc un une musique métal
tout à fait varié donc métal
expérimental métal progressif et des
séquences de cinéma voilà donc c'est le
groupe de clôture justement de de cette
édition et je vous propose d'écouter un
petit extrait et on se retrouve juste
[Musique]
après
alors vous le disiez les différents
groupes mêlent un petit peu un
différentes influences on l'a entendu
globalement sur cette affiche vous avez
privilégier une programmation variée un
dernier petit mot sur les tarifs les
modalités oui alors on a des préventes
donc pour chaque jour donc qui sont de
13 € par jour ou un passe 2 jours
disponible au tarif de 25 € donc vous
pouvez les retrouver sur notre site
metasos.fr sur notre page Facebook ou
directement sur notre billetterie en
ligne youticket parfait B très bien
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour toutes
ces précisions donc on le rappelle le
métal spphè a lieu les 12 et 13 mai
prochain à la salle de la tour de voisin
le Bretonneux m masuce vous attend
nombreux pour pouvoir êre banguer merci
beaucoup t merci et on va parler
technologie à présent créer son propre
robot c'est ce que propose l'atelier des
sciences à hencour un atelier pour les
plus jeunes pour assembler une petite
machine nous avons suivi une séance en
fait un robot voilà c'est une machine
qu'on force à faire un travail qui va
être capable de le faire toute seule
justement alors nous aujourd'hui on va
fabriquer ce petit robot capable
d'avancer en ligne droite et d'éviter
les obstacles ce robot paraît simple
mais sa construction demande quand même
un peu de pratique ces trois enfants
sont là pour apprendre j'ai j'ai fait
d'atelier les petits chercheurs à Gif
robotique et puis du coup j'avais envie
d'essayer ça permet de mieux savoir ce
qui se passe dans
un dénuder les fils assembler et souder
les composant chaque étape est réalisée
par les participants mais parfois avec
un peu d'aide Antoine est animateur pour
l'atelier des sciences son objectif
initier les plus jeunes à la technologie
de manière ludique on baigne dans cet
univers mais c'est pas pourutant qu'on
le comprend justement c'est on a on est
on a une approche on on a toutes ces
choses autour de nous mais on les
comprend pas forcément et justement bah
voilà l'atelier des sciences aide aussi
enfin ces petits ateliers servent aussi
à ça justement à à faire comprendre
justement l'univers scientifique qui
nous entoure des ateliers gratuit sur
réservation prochaine séance le 13 mai
sur le thème mécanisme et
[Musique]
engrenage et on retrouve Mélanie poet
pour notre rendez-vous junior et cette
semaine Mélanie vous nous présenteer un
événement pour les plus petits et pour
les parents on les oublie pas quand même
le samedi 13 mai c'est la fête de la
petite enfance de trappe alors comprenez
les enfants de 0 à 6 ans c'est des
destination des tout petits de leurs
parents et des futurs parents mais avant
d'en dire un peu plus on écoute la
responsable administrative du service
petite enfance donc l'objectif c'est
vraiment de présenter un petit peu le
projet petite enfance de la ville de
répondre aux questions des familles
d'offrir un temps festif aussi aux
parents et aux enfants là cette année on
est sur un thème qui a été travaillé par
une équipe enfin par nos équipes
pluridisciplinaires euh sur le thème de
construire et partager avec mon enfant
alors cet après-midi sera organisé
autour d'atelier de temps d'échange
entre parents et professionnels chaque
atelier mélangera des informations et
des jeux les parents pourront découvrir
les différentes structures de la ville
c'est-à-dire les possibilités de garde
mais aussi les activités la l d' tech la
baby gym il y aura aussi un atelier
autour de la séparation de l'autonomie
et un pôle alimentation autour d'un
grand goûter mais les tout petits ne
sont pas en reste on parle d'eux surtout
comme je disais précédemment les équipes
de la ville ont aussi prévu des
animations pour les principaux concernés
les enfants et là c'est Sarah qui nous
en dit un peu plus on va avoir des jeux
de construction un parcours
psychomoteur à l'aide d'objet de
récupération donc ce qui peut donner
aussi des idées aux parents pour jouer
avec leurs enfants chez eux on a
différents différents stands aussi enfin
différents accompagnements sur le livre
donc la médiathèque qui va intervenir
notamment la fête de la petite enfance
de trappe c'est donc le samedi 13 mai de
15h à 18h30 au gymnase Jean Guimier
merci Mélanie de nous avoir parlé de cet
événement et on passe maintenant à notre
[Musique]
agenda un événement à ne pas manquer
mercredi 10 mai le vélodrome national
accueille la Coupe de France de
l'Américaine une spécialité de cyclisme
sur piste couru en duo l'entrée est
gratuite pour les spectateurs dès 12h et
c'est la fin de ce 78 loisir merci de
nous avoir suivi je vous retrouve
vendredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
et je vous souhaite un excellent
[Musique]
weekend